welcome to another episode of not too
deep I'm your host grace and Helbig and
today we have such a fun guest I'm
talking to Austin kasabian aka aka is
his name
he's a 20 year old rapper singer music
producer fellow New Jerseyan woop woop
and he's got some really great stories
his voice is so cool I'm really into his
music and he's up-and-coming I think you
guys will love him he also has a
ridiculous story because of course being
from New Jersey he worked in an Italian
restaurant delivering pizza and one time
he delivered some meatballs and got some
extra meatballs as a tip you'll hear all
about it on this episode of not too deep
with a K are you tired of unpredictable
hair color results I bet you are
discover color and Co the home hair
color personalized just for you my
L'Oreal with coloring code you'll get a
free consultation with an expert hair
stylist who will custom blend a salon
quality shade for your hair needs no
matter your hair color goal you can do
it and use the promo code grace at color
and co.com for $10 off your first order
a que thank you for being here
how did a que become a que how did how
did you settle on the initials actually
it happened with my my xbox gamertag
like all you know infamous artists their
names come from their gamer tags yeah I
think was fifth grade uh-huh it was I
don't want to say it because I still use
it yeah it's a k47 and then my dad had a
motorcycle that was called some like a
specific thing I had like a bunch of
letters okay so I just threw the letters
at the end of ak-47 like back then I was
playing a lot of Halo okay anybody that
plays halo like you all know this but
like back then it was like you made
friends online yeah and you would always
like play with them yeah like I would
have homies that I play
only with like on Xbox I didn't know my
real name oh so they would just call me
a K instead of calling me the whole
thing and then eventually like it just
picked up in school yeah plane it's a
great quick right to the point name yeah
okay now a K for people that don't know
how do you explain I like to ask a lot
of people that wear many hats you're
wearing a bucket hat today but
metaphorically wear a lot of hats what's
your deal how do you explain what you do
to people honestly like I feel like it's
just expression I feel like my music is
very it's it's a hip-hop for sure yeah
but like in general when I make music my
goal isn't to make a specific sound like
okay whatever I'm feeling is like what
I'll portray mm-hmm so like if I'm if
I'm sad you're probably gonna hear me
sing more yeah I'm like if I'm like in
my bag like I'm feeling like I'm the man
like I'm gonna let you know that like a
mood ring yeah honestly yeah whatever
I'm feeling like my goal isn't to make a
sound my goal is to just express how I
feel cool
I mean it's cheaper than therapy yeah oh
no first how did this start cuz you're
very young you're 20 you're 20 and
you've been doing this you went viral
when you were 16 yeah okay 17 17 okay
so when did you start making music when
did you start using SoundCloud and
Spotify and all these things
SoundCloud was the first okay because
I've heard all the like tropes
stereotypes of like people DJ's getting
famous on soundcloud yeah I always
thought it was just like this joke but
no youyou did it yeah so to walk me
through that your [ __ ] curse is
broken what you're a fellow New Jerseyan
so you're from Jersey yeah I lived in
North Brunswick I lived I showed up
campus yeah for a long day [ __ ] I know
trust me and I did my research I know
we'll talk about fat sandwiches in a
little bit okay so how did the sound
cloud stuff start
all right so my brother mm-hmm when I
was in eighth grade mm-hmm seventh
eighth grade whatever okay my brother
had like a group with his friends and
they all wrapped okay and and they all
wrapped all of them wrapped it was like
it was like four or five of them got
themselves yeah drag them tell me for
this they call themselves the newbies
the newbies newbies newbies
so it's like the rap version of New Kids
on the Block I can't that's so funny cuz
like they didn't really like take it
serious like for you this is an older
brother yeah yeah okay so he was in I
think he was a senior mm-hmm and he left
to go visit one of his friends in
college okay and but he left a
microphone in a laptop in his room
he left it behind yeah so like after all
this time of me asking him like yo let
me help on a song with you guys he was
like no like you got to prove yourself
first like prove yourselves to get into
the to the newbies or whatever yeah so I
was like alright best so he left left
the laptop and mic in his room I took it
into mine and then recorded something
and then when he came back I played it
for him and then really that's how that
was the first thing I ever did that
that's how I was done yeah and so you
got his approval did he enjoy it oh yeah
now he was surprised he was like this is
like you actually are flowing and I do
you have a flow and what you're saying
makes sense like he was pretty shook
especially cuz I was like five years
younger than him yeah him but like since
then he kind of like veered away from it
mm-hmm and just left me with the mic in
laptop by my fingertips so I just kept
doing it
Wow and so you're doing it and then did
you know that SoundCloud was like at the
place that everyone was sharing all of
their like original music no at the time
I didn't it was actually somebody from
in my school mm-hmm found out that like
I rapped cuz I think I would rap in like
the lunchroom I [ __ ] I was that kid but
I remember I was in school I was walking
into the bathroom or some [ __ ] and some
kid came up to me and was like yo I
heard you rap I was like yeah and he was
like what's your soundcloud I was like
what's a SoundCloud like yeah is that
and then he explained it to me I was
like oh [ __ ]
so then then I that night this is when I
started posting on Sal oh and then I
don't see I don't know how SoundCloud
works in that way so you post it and
then you promote it and you're just
hoping that people come and listen yeah
I mean it's very similar to YouTube I
guess except not videos right right
right you kind of just like you share
the link with your friends and post it
on your Instagram Twitter or whatever
gotcha
yeah and then what was the turning point
like you did a remix right that went
huge oh yeah so the turning point of
okay um the Panda remix mm-hmm
so my best friend Mike he told me yo you
gotta take this Panda remix I was only
on soundcloud and he was like yo you got
to put this on another platform okay
he's like at the time I was I was 16 s 2
and it was our it was junior year he was
junior year end of junior year of high
school and he was like yo you're the
only 16 year old that remix panda like
this like it's it's wild what you did to
it being so young cuz everybody was
remix in it yeah and and that song was
really huge um and he he told me to take
a video of like either me doing a
one-take like walking on the street
we're just like right behind my
microphone and in my room so I was like
alright okay like I'll do it and then I
did it and then I put it on YouTube I
actually put it on YouTube on my 17th
birthday on your actual girl on my 17th
birthday July 18th yeah and then it
didn't do [ __ ] no seriously like it like
would get like 3 to 10 views a day
selection just you've sitting and
refreshing it this year I was yeah like
a Loki was like kind of upset because I
was like damn like I've liked this guy
yeah cuz it was the first time I ever
went behind them like in front of a
camera
oh that you're like your face yeah and
like if you watch a video like back then
I like I cringe watching it but like I'm
like oh like you guys didn't believe in
me whatever so like that was all like
unscripted but like it still was weird
for me to do I was in my bedroom staring
at a camera
I know but yeah especially for being my
first time I was like yo like I really
put myself out there and no one gave a
[ __ ] but I kept doing it and then
eventually that video sat by itself on
my channel until November of my senior
year okay and that's when what happened
it's hard to even like know like we have
no idea I woke up and it was at a
thousand views and I was like oh [ __ ]
that's good cuz on soundcloud i had
songs over a thousand views so like yeah
on youtube you was like alright cool
like if we can get that on youtube now
like let's continue yeah but then the
next day it was ten thousand and then
the next day it was a hundred thousand
and then by the end of the week it was a
million dang so like it happened so
quick yeah and what kept me going was my
brother was a big fan of like youtubers
and like in general like people on
YouTube and he was like yo the only way
you can continue like growing at this
rate is to be consistent yeah and like
at the time I was posting a song a month
on soundcloud and he was like yo you got
a deuce you if you want to continue this
momentum yeah you got to keep this up
like at least every two weeks post us
post a new remix he became basically
like your social media manager
immediately yeah cuz he was just as
stoked for me yeah yeah cuz he always I
feel like he always saw potential yeah
once once I played him that when he came
once you proved yourself but the did
people in your school know that they can
yeah yeah yeah how did that go um it was
cool yeah yeah it was definitely cool I
mean at the time it was like whatever
but like the year after is like when I
would like go visit that was when I was
like oh [ __ ] like people like asking for
pictures and [ __ ] it was cool friends
didn't really switch up too much like
too bad yeah a lot of new people tried
becoming friends because of it that's
fun
yeah but I was good at like I mean being
nice but like [ __ ] off yeah gentle [ __ ]
ah so it's like a very polite like
gracious [ __ ] I have enough like
emotional yeah bandwidth right now and
my friends so then
from there to now you just finished a
headlining tour right okay and this is
in the span of how many years from that
like the video
yeah yeah and Wow
okay with your brother's guidance did
you actually start uploading like
regular always sorry from the video
three years three and me signing my
management a year and a half okay
so then with your brother's guidance do
you start uploading regularly now now
it's quality over quantity for me yeah
so I've been putting a lot more cuz
everything's I'm independent so
everything's still out-of-pocket mmm
I have to I have to make sure that I'm
saving where I can write that all my
money towards putting it right back
Wow so like I have a lot of cool [ __ ] on
the way and I'm not trying to announce
any of it yet because I don't know
exactly when it's gonna be done but it's
coming soon okay
but it's something I've never done
before and people have been waiting a
very long time for it cool very excited
it's gonna be so crazy okay [ __ ] how
something you can talk about how was
tour you don't world as well 13 cities
13 or 14 years okay that's a lot yeah it
was well and that was your first tour
first tour ever yeah what take us what
were some of the highlights mmm the
highlights definitely like just [ __ ]
around at the hotels and [ __ ] was fun
yeah yeah those are always fun but uh
for the most part the shows were just so
crazy like really like cuz when I was
when I'd be done with the show I'd be in
the B in the green room not just be
thinking like like I'll always think
like then that just happened yeah when I
get onstage and then I get off it feels
like it was like ten minutes right but
really it was 45 right but like in the
moment I've like through the each show I
like knew I got more comfortable than
what I was doing and by the end it was
like I was I was so excited that we had
fun like finished that yeah just because
like I could check that off like I just
went on tour like what the [ __ ] that's
so cool so tribute we're there any what
were the weirdest moments
the weirdest moments were there any
weird fan I wasn't cut yeah there was a
couple people that like followed yeah
yeah but like it was it was whatever I
was nice to him mm-hmm cuz like I
understand what level I'm at right now
sure so like I'll take any time I feel
like it was in forget which city but we
were we were loading in and I guess fans
were there early and they went around
back to where we were
uh-huh to watch us load in and like they
kept yelling at me like yelling like a
kak and I was like I had to ignore them
for the time being because I had to load
everything in cuz it wasn't a huge crew
so I have to like I have to put the
merch out and [ __ ] and help but like I
came back out and they weren't there no
more but I was trying to set us up to
them so they're laughing that's my he
wasn't trying to be a [ __ ] yeah you
could next time just invite them to help
you load in and then you that's that's
more then you don't have to do as much
as you as you were do you want to do
another tour oh hell yeah yeah for sure
for sure
would you tour with someone else oh yeah
who are like your ideal like
collaborators that you would love to
work with like touring wise or like work
with either like make a song with go on
tour with get some lunch with Dan decide
to work with anybody Jay Cole okay I
know that's a long shot yeah for sure
for sure Jay Cole post Malone Kendrick
of course mm-hmm
I love young Doug I think young Doug is
[ __ ] great yeah but I mean I think
all this can happen yeah III think it
will I'm excited just bright very bright
but let's talk about your past for a
second you were a delivery driver for an
Italian restaurant but is that you still
currently employed there no not all the
time can you say what place it is
giuseppe's Oh
how long did you work there so my first
job was at another spot
in my town and delizia and I was
answering phones for like 7 bucks an
hour ok and I would I literally worked
answering phones for for like answering
the phones taking orders and like but
yeah it was another pizza shop and then
I would just answer take orders or
whatever and then once I turned 16 and
got my permit uh-huh my brother was
working at the other pizza shop
delivering so they didn't have anybody
answering phones like all the people
that already worked there did okay so
they were like yo let's just hire this
kid who will only do that and then we
could just focus on making the pizzas
something that's what I did there
you weren't really helping your brother
out constantly wasn't your brother doing
now like that's what you're gonna be
doing next my brother right now my
brother just he finished he finished
college last year something like that
congratulations your brother yeah
shoutouts ah yeah he's doing numbers for
a company right now but he's got he's
got bigger ideas bigger goal is that
he's working towards so I'm sorry for
him okay so you start answering phones
yep then do you start delivering pizzas
I deliver pizzas once I get my license I
got promoted
were there any weird pizza delivery
experiences I mean this is held like 90%
of porno stars but I'm wondering if
there any alternatives oh actually yes
no all right so it was it was an order
and it was literally the dude ordered
three meatballs it's like that is
technically harmless but that is
terrifying
he ordered he order three meatballs in
an orange Fanta and I was like all right
this guy could potentially try harming
me right so I walk up to the door I walk
up to the door and it was demos
awkward moment of my life no I ring the
doorbell like two minutes passes by he
comes to the door opens the door
this dude is butt-ass maybe wait the guy
that ordered only three meatballs and an
orange Fanta showed up to the door but
Nick but the [ __ ] naked and I didn't
know what to do I was just like I'd like
looked away and handed him the receipt
so you could sign it because it was a
credit card so I didn't have to like
change I would say yo you don't know
where that cash has been that was the
weirdest feets a story of my life
Wow I mean I literally have a question
that was did anyone ever answer the door
naked when you were delivering food and
so it turns out yeah yeah good job
Jersey keepin it [ __ ] weird okay we're
gonna take one quick break when we get
back I have a bunch more questions for
you and about what's coming up so we'll
be right back with more not too deep
[Music]
today we have support from ShoeDazzle if
you want to embellish your go-to outfits
and stable pieces with a new pair of
shoes without breaking the bank
you gotta check out ShoeDazzle every
month they did you a new selection of
exclusive and brand name shoes handbags
and more all you gotta do is take a
quick style quiz and then you'll get
your own custom online showroom with
items based on your own personal style
you can shop there or you can browse the
site freely to find the perfect style
for you it's for every person whether
your style is classic edgy feminine glam
etc etc you can check out as a guest or
become a VIP and get 30 to 50% off
regular prices plus free shipping on
orders over $39 I love ShoeDazzle like I
said I well I haven't said this you guys
can infer this by now I wear the same
pair of shoes over and over and over and
it's because I'm nervous about investing
in things that I may or may not like or
that I may eventually ruin and
ShoeDazzle gives me the freedom to look
for really fun pieces without
actually you know spending more than I
should
knowing my limitations as a glam goddess
you can get your first ShoeDazzle style
for as low as $10 as a VAP at ShoeDazzle
dot-com slash grace that's 75% off your
first item at ShoeDazzle comm slash
grace also get free shipping on orders
over $39 and there's no commitment when
you purchase your first order make sure
you enter your email address when you
take the style quiz to get exclusive
discounts and the inside scoop about new
collections again go to ShoeDazzle comm
slash grace sh o da z z le comte /g r a
c e terms and conditions apply today we
have support from Havre - it's the
newest and most affordable online wear
and return rental subscription for
everyday clothing you have the clothes
you have the staples of your wardrobe
you've invested in and then there are
the clothes that add a dash of color
print fashion or trend to your wardrobe
these are the pieces that you rent with
Havre - get it have or - have that you
get it fall in love with getting dressed
again with an endless rotation of
clothes you simply fill out your virtual
closet with everything you want to wear
have fun with new trends experiment with
things you would normally shy away from
buying get three items shipped at a time
and then wear them once or as often as
you want send back all three items to
get your next shipment of three and swap
out your items for new ones as often as
you want per month if you fall in love
with something you can buy it for a
discounted price get all of this for
just $59 a month check it out guys what
have you got to lose head over to have
her - comm and sign up today there are
no commitments and you can cancel
anytime
that's haberdash h AV ER da SH comm okay
we are back with a ke who has seen it
all
what's it like to self-produce your
tracks that was the something that I've
done for the first time recently yeah
cuz ignorance is bliss
the newest song I guess that you've
released as of when we're recording this
podcast is entirely self-produced by you
right what's that process like I mean is
it harder to not have anyone to like
collaborate with ah she liked it nicer
to have just creative freedom it's cool
to have creative freedom but at the same
time when you don't know as much as
you'd like
mm-hmm you kind of wish there was just
somebody there not saying anything but
like if you have a question you could
just ask real quick yeah yeah yeah and I
have a couple homies that are like that
but I know for sure like if I hit him up
I was a yo if we do a session I'm gonna
try to do everything but like you could
stick around provide some sort of like
yeah but that was it was it's such a
simple beat but I just felt like the
vibe was there so I didn't want to add
too much to it yeah but um yeah it was
so trippy cuz like I played the first
two chords I was like oh that works like
that makes sense because I don't know
how to read music oh really you know I
don't know any of that I got kicked out
of my music theory class in high school
because I didn't know how to read music
and she said that that was like
something that we had to know yeah and
like I was like what is that even like
aren't I here to learn that yeah but
look at you now but um yeah I just
played the first two chords I'm pretty
sure it's the C minor in G minor and I
was like where that's lit like that
works yeah so then I just kind of ran
with just the same uh those two chords
is literally the whole thing one's low
octave one the high octave Wow yeah I
just put some drums on it and then wrote
and then you make it sound so easy I
know I mean I didn't take it didn't take
as long as you'd probably think really
just because like I I guess it was just
one of those nights where like I really
was into it
everything was clear yeah everything was
clicking it was very simple yeah
everything's smooth that's very cool
yeah okay how powerful did you feel when
you first purchased some Apple earpods
Apple
pause ah I'm gonna keep it real yeah
I've never bought a parabola me either
yeah actually I still have I'm pretty
sure I walked in with wired once with
wired ones yeah sure they're tangled up
somewhere my bottom
yeah it's literally just like the most
stressful looking pile of cord that I
don't know why I haven't invested in air
pods I have tiny little baby ears so I
feel like they're gonna fall out all the
time okay what was the first physical
album that you purchased do you remember
it was finally famous by Big Sean oh
yeah how old were you [ __ ]
it was it was either sixth or seventh
grade but it was it was when I first got
my iPod mm-hmm
so I bought it on iTunes I can so I
wasn't like the physical copy right once
I cuz before I didn't before I had an
iPod I wasn't allowed to listen to like
anything with too bad cursing because I
had no device to listen to everything
was just whatever my mom was playing in
the car what are your what is your what
are your parents think about your music
now they love it really my biggest fans
really did they come to any shows my mom
went to Dallas she's been to Dallas with
me uh-huh
she's been to LA she's been no orlando
jacksonville washington DC atlanta wow
yeah she's been all over with me i don't
want to alarm you but I think your mom's
stalking but I'm I'm sorry sweetie
yeah like because I could tell it's love
like she ran she really like she's
really proud she's encouraging you yeah
that's all I mean that could go they'd
complete other ways that's not exactly
that's super cool okay what's the last
thing you hate watched you ever hate
watch anything hate watch I've never
even heard that term um it's it's a term
basically when you watch something you
know you don't like it but you watch it
just to kind of get pissed off at it hmm
maybe you're need an example of
something hmm like okay somebody hate
why I got well I used to hate watch
bachelor in paradise
cuz it's ridiculous
they love it so it's basically something
you watching her like why the [ __ ] in my
watch yeah like this is insane but I
can't stop looking at it the other day I
was in the house and toddlers and tiaras
was on yeah I bet it was down it goes
crazy yeah people they're insane I felt
so bad little children yeah talk about
curious mothering oh my it's so crazy I
hope I hope all that's fake but like I
have a feeling that it's like not really
yeah I think it's I think that one's
kind of pretty real yeah yeah yeah I saw
that it was just on I'm proud of you for
watching that I saw it I saw it on and I
was just sitting down I had nothing else
to do yeah I just sat on the couch and
watch it and on four episodes later I'm
like oh my god I'm still sitting here
just as interested as I was like
watching a car accident it's really hard
to not look at yeah exactly
what do you watch that you genuinely
love oh I love watching Chris D'Elia his
podcast oh yeah he's great oh that
[ __ ] guy's hilarious
I saw him live twice oh very cool I took
me me my dad and a couple of my homies
we went to see him in New York I was
back before and then me and my manager
saw him at the Laughing Factory
very cool he's actually from Jersey too
yeah I know I always say his last name
wrong but he's very very very funny yeah
what's the weirdest thing you've looked
up on Wikipedia hmm I saw you looked up
your own net worth the other day how fun
is that [ __ ] wait for people I don't
know tell them what you found alright
yeah so I'm worth 135 mil I would just
say that yeah so hard because like
alright so I was it was super late yeah
I was so tired but like I just didn't
feel like sleeping joy so I was just I
was just on my phone and I was like
looking up like Oh who's what's this
person's net worth is this person I was
like let me look up mine see if it's
yeah yeah and I don't expect to see
anything right so like I see I see it
says Austin kiss avians net worth
according to Forbes and this and that
and I'm like reading through them like
oh my god wait I'm about to find it so I
keep scrolling and then it just says 1 3
5 mil and I'm like I I start dying of
laughter like because it was the last
thing I expected to see that's so
bonkers I mean did they confuse like
you're like audio lessons with the
amount of do you think you get a dollar
for every like I literally was like yo
somebody had to have put that like
somebody had to know need to double
check like Postma loans and I was like
all right yeah oh [ __ ] I think it's like
I think it's like 16 mil so you have jet
like four times five times as much as
post Malone I mean that's obvious it's
so funny that is so yeah I would like to
meet the people that actually are
responsible for posting that it's also
just kind of like irresponsible because
your fans can go up and look at that and
think that you're this [ __ ] room
giant millionaire that's walking around
trying to be humble yeah it's so nuts oh
that's so bonkers do you look up dumb
things online a lot like that um usually
when I'm extremely bored yeah like I'll
just look up like some random [ __ ] i
watch a lot of like like um oh what is
that show you ever see the hunt on
Netflix I don't think so no wow what is
that it's all about like animals and
like the Predators versus the prey okay
it's like so it's like a nature show
yeah yeah but it's like it's trippy cuz
if they get they get really good shots
and it's like so wild to like watch that
[ __ ] yeah it's like if you ever watched
Planet Earth and those kind of things
that will freak your brain out yeah I
still don't believe it's all real I
still think some of its CGI and that
they are trying to prank us but that's
just me I'll save that for another
podcast
what's the dumbest thing that you
believed as a kid
way too long all right so for the
longest time and I was a kid I always
thought that like all right so like when
you get to be like an adult yes I
thought it was like you got to a certain
age and then it was like you're an adult
now and then everything is like
different like the whole world is
different you go through in like a
doorway and then all of a sudden every
not not like for real I thought it was
like you almost like sign a contract to
say like alright I'm an adult now and
you put the contract away wake up the
next day and it's like you're ready to
like it's like Dorothy everything's in
color and your closets just full of
suits and briefcases ya know like I
thought like that was how life worked
and then I realized that yeah I mean
technically I'm still like an adult
child I feel the same way like everyone
says like oh you're still a kid and I'm
like yeah I am but like I do adult
things so like I feel that event like
when I'm older I feel like I'm still
gonna be still gonna be rapping yeah
totally and also you have pressed into
this world that like most people your
age don't get to experience so you have
to adapt and like understand how it all
works
mm-hmm that grows you up that matures
you hmm um do you remember the smallest
crowd that you've ever performed for my
smallest crowd I think it was might have
been Jacksonville yeah
or orlando jacksonville orlando i think
it was like 45 really yeah that's cool
yeah no it was cool it was definitely
dope because like I treat every crowd
like it's twenty thousand yeah like I
love performing mm-hmm that's like one
of my like main things I love about like
my whole job yeah
but like I don't know I just feel like
when it's a smaller crowd you I could
litter I meet I can meet everybody after
the show much easier than some of the
other shows yeah you can have a more
intimate experience yeah like I don't
know there's just something about the
smaller shows that I really focus yeah I
think even when I outgrow these venues I
think it'll be dope to like go back
and like drop in and do tiny shows like
I feel like that would be so sick I
don't give you so much street cred to
people be like he's just like a snob I
just I just feel like that would be so
dope to like if I like eventually I want
to be able to do thousands yeah I like
what was your biggest show my biggest
show I ever did that was my show mhm
was 500 that's amazing back in Jersey
Jersey they showed us a report
esra Park oh yeah I'm tore the biggest
show was Cleveland Cleveland was nuts
could you tell the differences in crowds
from the different areas of the US [ __ ]
yes really
100% what was that one of the major
differences you saw the people South
Texas they go crazy Cleveland went crazy
uh-huh
I noticed I felt like when I was in New
York in LA like the entertainment city
yeah I felt like those were very like
people were afraid to like yeah no
[ __ ] nuts
yet people were more of like like
sitting there watching and like
observing observing rather than just
like y'all I'm out of a case show like
let me just go crazy yeah that's
interesting I've seen that a lot in LA
to it
that's only usually in the beginning
I'll call people out yo get the [ __ ]
yeah no one is safe yeah yeah I've taken
somebody on stage with me because they
weren't like they weren't getting lit I
had an extra mic on the same to me
sounds like yo you like do you know this
song yes I brought them up and I was
like oh that's good yeah and then the
rest of the show he's going [ __ ] nuts
so let that be a warning to anyone that
comes to your future shows is they have
to show up yeah majority of the time
they do but if they don't I'll make sure
things happen
um do you care about sports I do but
like I don't at the same time okay do
you a team or anyone that you
particularly root for I root for my
homies my friend Dante Strickland
he just got drafted to the Cardinals
he's a little gross I saw him play in
his first game preseason game whether we
very cool super dope so I'm room for him
over and a Z Co uh another one of my
friends most new he plays on the Falcons
cool your friends seem fun they're cool
they're doing really cool stuff they're
actually both they're both of them are
from south brunswick really yeah south
brunswick is producing all of these
athletes in art it's insane it's
actually nuts how many athletes come out
of South Brunswick well I know like
through the Rutgers like football
program and all of that that that's like
pretty intense for all of them yeah um
okay do-do you what's your airplane
routine since you're traveling so much
my airplane routine do you have like a
travel routine are there things that you
have to bring with you other things that
you you know not to do wow yeah there
there's some things um alright so I
always got a neck pillow you have a neck
pillow
oh because I I guess so much anxiety
before flights really yeah and I like
I'll do a red-eye mm-hmm I'll stay up
the whole night before say I'll fall
asleep so then and then I like I'll
force myself to stay awake all day and
at the read like when I have my flight
I'm like so exhausted there's no way I'm
not saying I have to have the neck
pillow on um my backpack always yeah um
my sister got me a my sister got me a
teddy bear like two years ago
ah because I was gonna be like traveling
and stuff uh-huh so and she's like told
me she want me to bring it or whatever
so I was like alright bit like so now I
take that everywhere that's real sweet
smoky shouldn't nobody know about so few
people run into you on a plane you're
gonna be wearing a neck pillow holding a
teddy bear okay do you celebrate your
birthday yeah
do you go big for your birthday uh not
really
usually alright so this was my birthday
just passed like this July and I was
home for it okay last year I wasn't so I
was here I didn't really do much I just
kicked it I don't managers house but um
this year what do we do I don't really
think we did much I just kicked it with
my homies back at the crib and then
and next year's your 21st birthday yeah
so that I'm trying to do you already
have plans for that not yet I'm gonna
start them soon because um I think I'm
the last to turn 21 of your friends like
my friends yeah oh man that'll be very
exciting and who knows we're gonna be by
the time your 21st birthday comes around
that's gonna be nuts do you remember the
first YouTube channel you subscribe to
see I never knew what subscribing to a
channel was until I had my own oh yeah
yeah so like I would just always search
who I wanted to watch ya know same it
took me like seven years before I
realized that I should subscribe to my
friends but you do there's buttons for I
just look them out there I was used to
look it up but um damn
I'm I think the first one was bigdhaas
TV I don't even know who that is
he's from Arizona oh cool yeah he's dope
um he just does like pranks that I
thought were hilarious at the time yeah
he still is wild he's nuts I've seen
I've been with him while he films oh no
and he's just super like he doesn't care
what people think about him are
dangerous but that's so dope like I like
I took so much from seeing him do that
like he had a speaker with him uh-huh
and he would play like old old music
like super old music in the 90s no old
Motown stuff yeah and then he would he
was just on that ASU campus and just
like with the boombox over so the same
song just dancing in the middle of the
[ __ ] walkway well like yeah now he's
a fun like I don't give a [ __ ] yeah
pranks make me anxious because I hate
when people are uncomfortable but that
kind of stuff is fun and harmless oh
yeah for sure hey who do you watch
YouTube now yeah who's your go-to did
that you watch now
probably david dobrik yeah yeah his
videos are just hilarious I don't know
when he sleeps if he sleeps yeah I
respect the [ __ ] out of him too yeah he
works his ass off yeah and he's a genius
very smart very smart very very
they in he's got a lot of innovation in
what he does it's very cool and who was
the last person you texted before he
went to bed last night my sister Oh cuz
I supposed to FaceTime her last night oh
and then she was like oh it's too late
cuz she's back in Jersey so you have
like a good relationship with your
siblings yeah for the most part yeah I
should call my brother that's on me okay
we're gonna take one last break when we
get back the internet I has a bunch of
questions that you've got to answer for
them because they are very uppity about
it
let's get it we'll be right back with a
K I'm not too deep after this if there
is something interfering with your
happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals better help online
counseling can help they offer licensed
professional counselors who are
specialized in issues like depression
anxiety relationships trauma anger
family conflicts LGBTQ matters grief
self-esteem and more connect with your
professional counselor in a safe and
private online environment get help at
your own time and at your own pace
anything you share is completely
confidential and it's so convenient you
can schedule secure video or phone
sessions as well as chat and text with
your therapists you can text with your
therapists amazing and if for some
reason you're not happy with the
counselor you can request a new one any
time for no additional charge it is
truly an affordable option and best of
all you beautiful listeners get 10% off
your first month with the discount code
grace so why not get started today go to
better help calm slash grace then you
fill out a questionnaire so that they
can help assess your needs and match you
with a counselor that you will love
again that's better help calm / grace
okay okay before we get to these Twitter
questions I'm gonna ask you the two
questions I ask every single guest that
is on the podcast Amy and the first is
who alive or dead would you most want to
throw cold spaghetti
yep you can take it in as someone that's
worked in an Italian restaurant so I
feel like this is gonna be an important
question cold spaghetti mm-hmm Wow yeah
I know my second grade teacher okay for
why she was just real mean oh I don't
really like her too much well okay and
this would be a harmless prank
yeah yeah exactly I could get in there
exactly Chuck some spaghetti get out of
there I'm out and then maybe she'll be
nicer for it maybe it'll be the wake-up
call she needs exactly okay the other
question is to tell us your worst pant
shiting story
well [ __ ] students yeah we're close
call but you can only use three words or
small phrases to mine for example is
college jogging front lawn it was not
funny at the time
oh okay um [ __ ] I was oh I know I gotta
keep it short yeah it's preprints or
like small raises okay okay whatever
paints the picture all right fan family
vacation okay whitewater rafting
oh no and just being scared I guess I
don't even remember how old that was it
wasn't recent okay it's like either way
was alien wolf whitewater rafting is
dangerous I mean it's just like you're
in one giant toilet the whole time no it
was it was honestly even though I'm not
supposed to describe y'all happen but it
was like it was at a time like I didn't
feel good the whole day yeah and it was
like it was at a time where we were like
able to jump out of the raft and it was
like calm water so I jumped out of the
Wrath and I was just like gotta do so
gross so [ __ ] nasty
but like my talking about self was like
dude you got to do it
doing what I'll see you gonna do I mean
and it brought your family closer
together I'm sure oh my god my my my
family thought it was so funny
they still talk about it okay let's get
into these Twitter questions someone to
know someone says I love you and when's
the next concert in LA mmm well I love
you too wait a minute
it's her oh gee oh gee Delilah yeah yeah
Delilah Giselle where oh yeah yeah no
I'm I didn't I didn't see that last
night but I seen she tweets at me all
the time asking like when I'm gonna do a
show in LA oh cool so I see you but I
don't have any other show dates lined up
across the US or international and my
agent is working on that right now
cool yeah we might we might try to do a
part two of the no rest but that'll be I
mean obviously won't be called a no rest
or um yeah we're trying to get some some
of the worst so just stay following a
que no social platforms and you'll know
exactly when any dates get announced
there's so many questions about is there
an album coming this year
ah and you can evade this question if
you don't want to give a specific yeah
yeah yeah I'm gonna just say I'm working
working things are hot deers are in
motion yeah not for sure for sure very
cool very ominous mmm which basically
means yes because that wasn't no but you
don't know when exciting okay
this question was interesting to me um
be 5sos says coming from someone who has
never heard of you until now what would
you most like to be known for if you're
a musician what song or if you're
musician what song or what wouldn't you
like to be known for that you are this
is a very weirdly worded question
basically what do I want to be known
what do you want to be known for yeah if
someone did who was just discovering you
what path would you put them on what
would you show them to like show the
best like version of you to them yeah
like I feel like my goal the way I
want to be viewed in the way I want
people to know me for what I want people
to know me for it's just like I guess
it's to remind be themselves cuz that's
something I you I I mean I still
struggle with this sometimes but I've
gotten much better with just like who
gives a [ __ ]
like what yes I think like just be
yourself well that's what see I didn't
really know much about you until the
last couple weeks and that's what I
really thought was so cool about you is
that you wear whatever you want you your
videos are like very beautiful very
artistic your voice is rad
it's like you can do all different
styles of rapping and singing which a
lot of people cannot do and your tone
has just like a more mature tone to it
like it sounds you sound way older than
20 years old so it's not like this fluff
like [ __ ] kind of like easily
produced style feel that what is there a
song that you would recommend to people
to listen to first if they're
discovering you for the first time that
you think like represents what you're
doing um damn I would probably say if I
had to say the first song like I got it
for sure yeah yeah I feel like that song
is just very it's a very statement song
cool yeah it's very it's very high I
feel like it's an attention catcher very
cool um okay
Josefin kid wants to know what's his
favorite thing about being an artist
connecting with people yeah yeah cuz
that's something I used to I used to
struggle with a lot like in school
mm-hmm because I never would like like I
had friends and like I was when say I
was popular like a lot of kids knew me I
knew a lot of kids but like I had a very
small group of friends that I'd like
hang out with outside of school but I
feel like I always was I was always in
my head
like I was always mad insecure like
always overthinking and like trying to
be like the perfect person for towards
everyone yeah in like I would kind of
forget about my own happiness by doing
that and then eventually like I feel
like that kind of kept me from
connecting with a lot of people that I
could have mmm I just remembered to just
be myself and not give a [ __ ] yeah do
you get it you must get a lot of
messages from people and that resonate
and relate with you that are like they
being yourself you're giving me
permission to be my exactly and that's
when I'm like because I didn't really
have that when I was mmm-hmm struggling
with that so now that I'm a vessel for
other people to be like yo like just be
yourself like that's the sickest [ __ ]
ever that isn't it cool to be rewarded
for just being you exactly after all
this time like struggling yeah people
aren't gonna [ __ ] with me if I'm being
me you know but that's awesome because
then your music becomes more personal it
becomes a way for you to actually like
express all of the dialogue that happens
inside your head constantly mm-hmm
people asking one or more shows
happening happening album dropping soon
shows a very soon shows are soon okay um
Tyler Mickelson wants to know what's
your songwriting process do journal or
do you write down like thoughts feelings
emotions very crazy I just started
journaling on my road to finding myself
I started doing that is that the name of
the new album nah but like I feel like
in the past like month and a half two
months uh-huh I've kind of just been
trying to like find Who I am like on
like the deepest level yeah what I'm
trying to be Who I am and like who I'm
trying to be to everyone around me and I
feel like I never knew like I always
felt like everything was closing in on
me
because I would just like get all
anxious about it so I was like what can
I do besides writing songs that could
help me get all the [ __ ] out yeah cuz I
feel like writing songs it's very
therapeutic but at the same time it
[ __ ] me up because like oh I'll have to
be writing about something that I don't
want to be like getting into detail
about it'll keep reminding me of like
all the [ __ ] yeah but I started
journaling every night before I go to
bed and then that's the literally just
changed my whole life really actually
has helped me so much Wow
that's really cool and I'm sure that
probably then by default helps your
writing songwriting process percent yeah
because I feel like I'm just always I'm
always expressing myself but not in the
same exact way every time right right
right
are there topics or emotional things
that have been too deep for you to tap
into yet that you know you eventually
want to get into in terms of like
writing songs about not really no I feel
like you're an open book
truly for me I feel like it's so easy to
not talk about it
but once you just say it yeah into the
mic it's and it sounds good and you are
happy with the way it sounds mm-hmm even
though it's super super deep and super
personal and you don't want nobody to
hear it I don't have to watch somebody
listen to it you know I'm saying yeah
I can just put it out and then they hear
it and they are either like oh my god
that's sick I feel that well they're
like yeah [ __ ] it I don't really care so
like for me I don't have to sit there
and watch somebody like yes and to me
get all open yeah that's how I feel
about my therapy I had to watch my
therapist listen to me say sad things I
should just close my eyes next time I
tell no who is your inspiration or what
is your inspiration my inspiration right
now is my family for sure really yeah do
you have songs about family members oh
yeah
I talk about my mom a lot my songs yeah
I'm sure she loved that oh my gosh does
she rap will there be a mother-son
collaborative song I mean probably never
released on the track like I'm down play
listen to the [ __ ] out of that okay this
question is really interesting and it's
a little bit more serious from no [ __ ]
eight to nine three seven eight six five
rolls off the tongue
they say he always says he wants to be
the greatest but never made it clear
what is so special about him what does
he have that will make him stand out in
his prime and then they said I really
don't want some generic answer like
mindset energy hunger this person is
very demanding yeah where they also
though yeah they're there handle profile
picture is just a cat with the words no
[ __ ] under it so real serious stuff yeah
damn I feel like the way I approach
every song and the way I approach
everything that has to do with music
yeah I've always felt it in my heart
that like there's something different
and like I know that and like I used to
I used to acknowledge it but now like I
own that [ __ ] I'm saying and that
changed everything so like once I
started really like honing in and
focusing on owning that part of me like
knowing that there's something about me
that's different yeah like everybody
always talks about like oh like he's
dope but like or not not to me
specifically but just in general it's
like yeah they're cool but like they
don't have that spark mm-hmm I feel like
I have that hmm and I feel like I own
that because I'm I'm proud of that yes I
know how uncommon it is for that yeah I
mean I think there's a lot of people
that are confident without the means to
back it up and then alternatively I
think there's a lot of people that are
afraid of success and so they
self-sabotage in a way and they don't
they they don't appreciate their talents
and like like you are saying like they
don't give themselves permission to
accept them and not feel like ashamed to
like be so confident 100% and that's
also something that I I've battled with
all that before and like I said I do a
little bit but like for the most part
like I'm always I'm like even with the
journaling like I constantly am keeping
myself in check like yo tomorrow's gonna
be an even better day than today even
though today was dope like it's always
gonna continue getting better I'm like I
don't know I just feel like my my voice
is different I just feel like my voices
I think you have a natural-born Talent
and the fact that you're actually
utilizing that talent in a really
interesting way rather than like a
generic like I'm gonna go on American
Idol and like sing pop songs kind of way
I think it's very cool and you're just
at the start of everything you know the
beginning yeah I think it's awesome
what's your biggest pet peeve mmm
my biggest pet peeve white lies white
lies yeah like little lies that like
don't mean [ __ ] if you just say the
truth a waste of breath yeah okay last
question what's a question you hate
being asked and what's a question you
always wanted to be asked I've seen that
I've seen somebody ask that yeah one
thing I hate to be asked when is the new
song coming because like I'll put out a
song uh-huh and literally like the
second I post it somebody will comment
oh this is cool when's the next one I'm
like bro I just spent four weeks
straight trying to get that video done
it get that [ __ ] mixed mastered like all
that and I just drop yeah just dropped
crazy but like it's cool they don't get
all that background yeah yeah they don't
get to see all the behind the scenes
like that and know how much like blood
sweat and tears go into it what's the
question that you wish you were asked
more often I don't really know I feel
like I haven't done enough interviews
like no yet but like yeah I'm not sure
soon
soon you'll find it soon oh okay here's
last one how important is it for you to
stay connected with the fans and
creators and the creators showing
support to your success I think it's
super important yeah that's like
something I've really tried to focus on
I try I try to answer as many teams as I
can today yeah yeah a lot of people feel
offended when I don't respond to their
DMS and then they'll DM me like they'll
be like oh I'll respond to somebody yeah
and then I won't respond again for like
a couple days or like oh really like
maybe a month or two and then but I'll
be responding to other people's the ends
because I connected with him yeah and
like I'm trying to get to everybody yeah
but then like I'll get dm's like oh you
don't answer your fans anymore and I
literally this happened two days ago and
I was like yo dude I'm trying that's it
yeah bro I'm like I know I don't have to
like I don't have to even respond to
that and be like yo and like explain
myself but like at the same time I just
want them to know like yo it's like it's
all love I'm not like ignoring you like
yeah and your intentions are good you
don't have to respond to a DM period but
the fact that you're even like venturing
in that world and staying connected to
your friends like that I think is huge
this has been so fun thank you for
making time and talking with us before
you leave every guest that makes time to
be on not too deep gets a personalized
fortune cookie as a parting gift from us
to you so you can feel free to open it
up and um and read the fortune that's
inside has never happened to me before
in my life with that I just broke it in
half and usually it's like right there
oh yeah oh [ __ ]
surprise Congrats on that 135 million
net worth bro where the [ __ ] you guys we
will take it graciously my checkbook and
with me thank you okay where can people
find you and everything that you're up
to if they don't already know you can
find me at I am the relay okay I am the
real okay okay on all social media every
single platform on soundcloud the relay
que you could just type in a que and
then it'll come up great yeah and you
guys might get music you might get an
album you might actually get music for
sure for sure yeah in the near to
distant future and hopefully a mom track
fingers crossed fingers crossed
thank you a que this was so fun guys go
check him out if you haven't already it
is worth your time and we'll see you
guys next time on another episode of not
too deep goodbye to deep deep deep
whatever struggles you are facing
depression anxiety trauma grief better
help can connect you with a professional
counselor in a safe and private online
environment it is so convenient you can
schedule secure video or phone sessions
as well as chat and text with your
therapist anything you share is
completely confidential and best of all
its truly affordable and you will get
10% off your first month with the
discount code grace so why not get
started go to better help calm slash
Grace fill out a questionnaire and get
matched with a counselor that you love
today not
is a production of grace helbig
incorporated producer Melissa Dumont's
writing by Diane Kang a production
assistants by Katrina Henning post
production sound by Chris Henry and an
extra special thanks to Flula for the
theme music
[Music]